welcome back the viva las vegas
rockabilly weekend who is sponsoring
this segment is happening this weekend
at the orleans music cars fashion and
food you're gonna find it all and i
stopped by earlier for a sneak peek
welcome to viva las vegas welcome to the
world's largest rockabilly festival now
the man behind it all this is tom tom
thanks for having us my first question
is what is rockabilly rockabilly
originally was a form of 50s music
which was just before rock and roll with
people like elvis carl perkins julie
lewis people like that but now it's so
much more it's become used as a term for
all types of 50s music
and things associated with that scene i
love it and that's what we're
celebrating this weekend it's a huge
festival we're going to walk here
because there's so much going on
happening right now at the orleans we've
got cars we'll get to them in a second
but talk about the music that's taking
place this weekend
it's all 50 style rock rock and roll
rockabilly rhythm and blues do [ __ ] but
it's mainly younger bands of today who
are playing the music and you have like
there's like burlesque shows and fashion
shows taking place we've got burlesque
shows there's like six performances of
burlesque bingo there's three
performances of the burles showcase and
the burlesque competition we've got
vendors who are selling everything
connected to the scene everything we do
here has to be connected to
like the late 50s early 60s as far as
the clothing too because i see people
walking around it's open right now see
people walking around that are kind of
that rockabilly look going to them
there's fashion shows and people can buy
rockabilly clothes yes i mean you don't
have to be wearing
50 style clothes to come here but
majority of people do and for a lot of
people this is their time once a year
where they're really dressing up and
they've been buying clothes searching
for clothes all year just for this
weekend and the car show that's
happening this weekend this i mean it's
one of the country's biggest car shows
you have over 500 cars but there is a
stipulation i don't know if you've
noticed we're walking through and
looking at these incredible vehicles
they all have a theme what's the one
stipulation with your cars every car has
to be built before 1964 and it has to be
period correct so because it fits that
rockabilly feel yeah so it's as a car
would have been back then
so if someone goes and spends a fortune
making it look with modern stuff on it
if we can't see it it's okay but
basically the exterior has to look as it
would have done there yeah this one i
mean we see we see we see the rockabilly
the old school look but it definitely
has kind of that modern feel to it you
can tell they restored and modified
these seats it's it's a gorgeous look to
it i mean look at the uh the octopus
skull shifter i don't think they had
that back in the 50s but it kind of fits
the vibe of the car yeah it does it fits
the vibe of the car and so it's not
really really strict because there's a
lot of
expanding on what would have been done
then
kind of modernizing it too now the car
show people come down and see the cars
today but a lot of the cars will be out
on display tomorrow saturday afternoon
right saturday's a big day where we have
the most cars we've got the stage with a
load of live bands playing and
over a hundred vendors as well so much
going on here food and food too yes i'm
gonna have to get my rockabilly shirt to
come out here tomorrow it's me a great
time a great time tom thank you so much
thank you appreciate it thanks a lot
appreciate it
thank you viva las vegas rockabilly
weekend for sponsoring this segment
catch it it's actually started today it
runs through sunday at the orleans and
you can walk right up and get tickets or
if you'd like to you can visit viva las
vegas dot net las vegas will be right